تميل الكلاب إلى أن تكون ركابًا بارزين
يأخذون عجلة القيادة
في الغالب في الأفلام أو الكتب ، لكن إليك واحدًا
للكتب التي تحطمت السيارة التي تحطمت فيها
السيارة التي
قمت بعمل قطع مضحكة عن
قيادة الكلاب ، أعلم أن لديك
رخصة كلب ولكن هل لديك رخصة متعلم
اسمح لأي منكم بالحصول على تصاريح المتعلمين
وقبل عقد من الزمان في نيوزيلندا ،
فقط عندما كنت تعتقد أنك رأيت كل شيء
، حاولوا تعليم العديد من الكلاب
لقيادة نقل التروس ،
نعم ، لكن بوردر كولي الذي
قفز خلف عجلة قيادة هذه السيارة الجيب
متوقفة في ممر في ويلز
لم يأخذ أي دروس
هو أن مالك الكلب الذي حاول
عبثًا إيقاف الجيب
على الأقل أن Shaggy Dog سرق
سيارتي ولم يرتكب Border
Collie جناية تم التقاط الحادث بواسطة
كاميرا أمنية  ينتمي إلى Sean Waller
الذي تضررت سيارته لكنه يقول إننا
لسنا غاضبين على الإطلاق ، حدثت حوادث
، جعل صاحب الكلب الكلب يتخلى
عن العجلة التي
سئل عن التأمين ، أخبر Waller CNN أنني
أشك في أن الكلب قد ورد اسمه في البوليصة.
على كل حال ، سيتعين علينا المطالبة من خلال
التأمين على الحيوانات الأليفة بدلاً من ذلك ، ولكن قبل أن
ترفع أقساط الكلاب هذه ، ضع في اعتبارك
أنه لم يظهر واحدة من
أفضل 10 علامات لديفيد ليترمان أن
كلبك سائق سيء دائمًا ما يبتعد عن
الطريق ليلعق نفسه CNN
نيويورك